let's go to something balling out in the
in the store how about that what you got
yeah walk us through this richard
so like you can get better selection of
luxury goods here in miami than you can
get where they're manufactured so if you
go shopping in italy or france the
selection is trash compared to belhard
this is the design district in miami i'm
very familiar with this i live five
minutes away from there so what'd you
buy oh this was like a couple track
suits a jacket a set like i was missing
the pants for a set like a tracksuit set
i was able to find those there
um
i actually had some hexagon shaped
notepads at gucci i was like i got some
of those
and then at prada oh man prada okay i
love crystal stuff so like this here is
a giuseppe
i don't remember his last name
just happy something zenodi
they're crystal but see with the shoes
yeah with colored and they have spikes
spikes and crystals so this like spikes
is like valentino laboutine and
crystal's kind of like everybody's
getting on that game now so i've got
alexander mcqueen crystal i've got louis
vuitton crystal i got
product crystal the product ones are the
best product ones at the best price
point so louis vuitton ones were 5 550
and
the prada ones is only like here they
would be maybe 1800
but the crystals sparkle harder they're
more durable they're more reliable but
here's the problem these stores when
they get them they hide them because
it's like the unique special hard to get
stuff
and so if you're on a website trying to
get it they're just sold out you can't
get them like you got to roll up in
europe i literally couldn't get my size
i wear a size 12 like a 46
and then
it depends on the shoe like the boutique
is small like 46 47 48. so i had to call
them i had to like order it to my mom's
house
because they had it in america right so
i was able to get one size 12. but then
it took me like a year to get here to
like get it
but then i went to the i went to the
design district and i was like yeah we
got them hit in the back i'm like oh my
god give me all of them that you can
give me they're like we've only got one
of each size i'm like okay fine give me
so i got a black crystal set white
crystal set they were hidden in the back
you couldn't get them online they were
sold out so this bothers me like prada
is an italian brand and when i'm in
europe i'm getting better product select
and i even have rep like i spent a lot
of money i have like an assignment yeah
when when when the salesperson at gucci
prada louie all that
sees richard heart walk in they're like
i just made my commission for the
[ __ ] day yeah louis vuitton flies me
to paris for fashion week puts me in a
hotel that hotel is like 2 000 a night
like easy
and tries to sell me stuff so like 155
000
well here it will probably be 225 000
you know case to put your shoes the most
expensive piece of clothing you've ever
bought you know the diamond i believe
you could not jewelry that i think the
diamond cost a little over four million
bucks from what i understand yeah but
you know it's worth more than that that
i got a great deal you got a good deal i
i i was tactical with that
i'm like yo this is for hexagon cultural
heritage
the maximum stake you can do on hex is 5
55 days so we have a lot of people to do
that and get quattrosenko like four
fives tattooed mm-hmm and then without
the maximum yeah five five five five
yeah and then that's how many years is
that about 15. so that people are
willing to wait 15 years for their total
return average stake length of hexa
seven years okay you got to have a lot
of 15-year stakes to get an average of
seven right it's really mind-blowing i
mean it has never been it keeps getting
longer i can tell you why it keeps
getting longer it it's the system is
amazing like people don't understand how
high the price can go we went up 10 000
x on just 100 000 stakers we just
recently put on five thousand in the
last on a couple weeks that's not many
people i mean every stupid thing out
there has more
like we're what's the minimum
nothing there's no minimum no minimum
stake one 100 millionth of a hex hex is
like six cents so a hundred millionth of
six cents i gotta give a shout out
because i never heard of hex that would
be frank um that's right
you're you know jorita urita yeah yeah
yeah okay she's probably watching this
freaking out right now jory respect um
she's cool she's like she she's hooked
up with a hexagonal hexagon brush i
think so yeah so anyway the most
expensive piece of clothing yeah so like
i mean
clothing does the million dollar
bulgarian jewelry count no not clothing
um consider clothing but not really
i would say like probably my prada
jackets are like eight grand each like
the sequin project is 50 grand what was
the switch cause you said you weren't
into style so like what was it just like
you made money you're like i like
clothes now like what was it there you
just so basically when you want to
you master something you get into it and
then you max it out and you get your end
game and you're done so like watches i
own them all like i'm done well it was
like your first piece you were like i
want to start buying shoes first or
watches like what was your
how did you do your investment pieces
like so to dress up louis vuitton i want
something that speaks at a distance
so if you get like ferragamo
gucci
prada and it's just black with a logo on
it no one can tell what that is it could
be zara it could be anything right so if
you want something that shows i spent
too much on this therefore you should
like me more
then it's got to be either very colorful
with a known monogram or monogram print
or for instance bottega venetta green
they own that color pretty much louis
vuitton brown they own that color pretty
much and then you know it
when i punch with monogram or
very specific color it it punches at
like 30 40 yards and so you don't have
to be on top of me to see it right yeah
so like these dg glasses these are
obviously dj glasses you're going to see
these from max it's like marketing
you're finding the best items to kind of
market the products and then from there
and they have a durable value as well so
on my louis stuff like i have a louis
vuitton airplane bag that was forty
thousand bucks i ain't gonna lose money
in that there's only a couple in the
world like i'm gonna make money on that
right so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire saucecast click
right here
[Music]